hi everybody my talk is called behind
the New York Times crossword before I
begin the first thing I want to say is
just that strange loop is one of the
best conferences that I've ever had the
pleasure of attending and now speaking
at if you are looking at the schedule
and trying to debate which talks you
want to go to I highly suggest going to
the talks that have nothing to do with
your interests or careers go to the
weirdest talks that you can find if you
read the title and you don't know what
it means you should go to that talk
because all the talks are gonna be
online by the end of the day anyway so
you just watch those on company time you
know get paid to do it so go explore a
little bit so that's my forward I do
have to preface this by saying I'm
giving this talk on behalf of the New
York Times as of last month I do not
work in the New York Times anymore I
left on my own volition for another
opportunity with another company but
they gave me I'd already accepted to
give this talk before I'd left and they
gave me permission to still give it
provided that I say that I don't work
there anymore and say that or don't
reveal any corporate secrets which I'll
try not to do so Who am I my name is
Darren I joined The Times in 2015 I was
hired out of college I actually joined
the times because I watched a video
online given by one of their senior
engineers about how they use go at the
New York Times and I had no interest in
writing go but I thought that was such a
cool progressive thing for a company
that you'd think would be old and stodgy
and stuck in its ways I thought that was
really progressive of them so I applied
and back in the day you could just apply
by emailing them your resume I'm really
upset that that system is gone but
either way I joined I became a go
developer at the times and then I was
actually recruited by the engineer who
gave that talk on to the games team in
2016 and that's where I worked for the
night for the rest of my career at the
times and while I was there I was also a
member of the architecture review board
where we helped guide process and new
tech
oh geez within the company so if you're
sitting here by now you've probably
realized that the New York Times games
team is a thing we have won we have an
entire team dedicated just to games the
game team was responsible for running
the games platform which hosts a series
of games and supports over half a
million paying subscribers if you
subscribe to The Times you would know
that you can get the news or you can get
the crossword or you can get both but
you have to pay more for the crossword
you doesn't just come with your new
subscription but what does the games
team the games team is essentially a
company within a company it's run as a
start-up within the umbrella of the New
York Times what I mean by that is that
it's entirely self-contained this group
could be sold off and continue to
operate as a company separate from the
New York Times and it has all the things
it needs a normal everything a normal
company would need it has its own
editorial staff it's got front-end
engineers back-end engineers it's got a
bunch of different mobile engineers
Android iOS we support Kindle we support
Windows tablets it's got its own QA test
automation team its own design team its
own management structure even its own
marketing and Finance and its own profit
and loss system and lastly we have our
own game maker who's in charge of
creating new games so what games does
the new x games team deal with well
there's a couple logic games Sudoku said
set and KenKen and then there's our new
games these are part of our games
expansion the first one we launched was
spelling bee which was a feature in the
actual paper for a long time we
digitized it letter box is another
anagram game where you try and connect
all the letters together by entering in
words and trying to use up all the
letters and
words as possible and then our latest
game tiles came out earlier this year
tiles is interesting because it's our
first non word game of the expansion
this is really important for us because
this is this increases the accessibility
of our games we understand that not
everyone is a native English speaker so
we wanted to create something that
someone who doesn't speak English
natively could play and enjoy but then
there's the og a real bread-and-butter
The New York Times crossword which I'm
sure we've all heard of some of us play
some of us may play avidly some of our
parents might play avidly and what does
it look like it looks like this
most crosswords look just like this it's
a 15 by 15 cell grid it's filled with
different words and abbreviations and
phrases and sometimes they have a theme
they have rotational symmetry you can
rotate this 180 degrees it would be the
same board why is that a requirement
because the first puzzle master thought
that it just looked prettier and then
we've stuck with it ever since and you
could play this on a variety of devices
like I said you could play it on your
phone you can play it on your desktop
you can play it on your kindle and we
can track your progress across all of
these devices so you could play it on
your work computer in the morning and
then you could finish it on the bus home
at the end of the day who edits these
puzzles well there's Will Shortz Will
Shortz is probably someone you may have
heard of he was on The Simpsons
he is our puzzle master I believe he's
still the only person on the planet with
a degree in puzzle making he has a
degree in the Enigma tala gee he's our
puzzle man he's been our puzzle master
since 1993 we call this the short Seon
era of puzzles but he has two assistants
he's got Joe Foley on Oh
who is holding a cross word that says
thank you Joel
you rushed my life for some reason I
don't know what that means and then
there is a Joel as well as editing the
puzzle also creates the mini everyday
the mini crossword and then there's Sam
Mazursky our newest he's looking a
little more cartoonish than he does
usually but this is Sam and then the
last piece of our editorial staff is
actually deb emmalin she's our crossword
columnist so we have someone who writes
about the crossword she writes a blog
called wordplay leaves she's been doing
it since around 2011 and she writes
articles like this
she writes how to construct a crossword
how to play a crossword really helpful
are tough articles to allow people to
get into crossword puzzles and also
expand their skills with crossword
puzzles one of the things she does and
that our back-end architecture actually
supports as she writes this column
called what the heck is that where she
picks a word from the crossword that
stumbled a lot of users that they
couldn't guess we actually derived this
from our puzzle data using bigquery we
run a query to see of the crosswords
which word was revealed the most and
then she picks it and she writes an
article about it saying like this is
some obscure word that someone put into
a crossword to fit a little corner
somewhere and here's what it actually is
for the record a MOA is an extinct emu
like bird from New Zealand so now you
all know that congratulations so the
history of the crossword the crossword
has existed since around the 20s but it
wasn't a regular thing in the paper
until the 1940s in fact one of the
editors of the puzzles one of the souls
burger is called it a primitive form of
mental exercise he didn't feel that the
crossword deserved space
the venerated gray lady he thought that
that would belittle the entire paper and
then something happened and then Pearl
Harbor happens and they decided that if
people are gonna be getting the paper
every day there's going to be a lot of
bad news in it and so that they should
give something to their readers to look
forward to when they get the puzzle so
they decided you know we we ought to
proceed with the puzzle these are dark
times we need some form of relaxation
for our readers and this was two weeks
after he had said the the previous quote
but what goes into a crossword
crosswords have themes they're not just
a random assembly of words and phrases
puzzles Monday through Thursday and then
Sunday all have a specific theme they
all have a commonality between a set of
words this one this is actually from
Tuesday you'll see the coolest sandwich
whose initials have been rearranged in
five other ways in this puzzle so the
answer that this one is BLT if you look
at the longest words going across you'll
see that they all start with the
combination of letters BL and T born too
late this looks bad lower back tattoo so
it gives you a kind of satisfying little
Easter Egg in the puzzle every day for
you to figure out and it can help you
solve and part of the challenge of
making a crossword is coming up with a
good original theme another thing that a
lot of people don't know about the
crossword is that it actually gets more
difficult throughout the week on Monday
it'll be generally the easiest puzzle
the clues will be the most
straightforward the theme won't be super
tricky and it'll get gradually harder
throughout the week this is just for a
variety so you know different classes of
players can all play every week and
enjoy the puzzle
it's hard throughout the week Thursday's
are tricky they usually have some sort
of riddle in them the theme is usually a
bit cryptic and you really have to
figure it out in fact Deb Emlyn our
common our columnist does a live
crossword solve every Thursday where she
gets on to periscope and screen shares
and actually works out the puzzle with
users just a lot of fun saturday is the
hardest puzzle it has the most cryptic
clues that everything I remember when I
first started every every clue felt like
a riddle
we're like the straightforward answer
was never it you always had to go for
the second well less clear answer and
then some days are generally around a
Wednesday and Thursday difficulty but
there you get a much larger puzzle
visitor 21 by 21 instead of 15 by 15 so
some of the difficulty is just how long
it takes you to solve it because there's
more clues and more words and a lot of
people's progress kind of looks like
this
this is actually mine for March where I
was able to successfully Goldstar all of
the Monday puzzles I was able to do all
of the Tuesday and Wednesday puzzles and
then you kind of see that throughout the
week it it fades a little bit I could
you know I'll twiddle on the crossword
like on the subway but I probably won't
finish it especially on a Saturday I
might have things going on I'm not gonna
be able to get super far but I was able
to Goldstar all of the Monday's you can
gold a puzzle by completing it on the
day that it comes out without using any
of the tools that we have to cheat no
checking and no revealing and I actually
did an analysis of this so you if you
actually create a heat map of all of the
board's ordered by week you can see a
representation of almost how difficult
it might be by seeing where all of the
black squares fall so the darker black
or red the color is the more likely that
cell
for that giving day is going to be a
black square so you notice that Monday
Tuesday and Wednesday but the top all
look very similar and the thing to call
out here is that they have two dark
spots on each edge which indicates that
more often than not we're breaking up
the edges into three smaller words
whereas if you look at Saturday you'll
see that there's only one grouping
around the edge so usually there will be
too much longer words and longer words
tend to be a little more obscure and a
little more difficult to guess and then
Sunday just because of its size is super
varied there's a lot of different
patterns you could have in the puzzle
but it still maintains that symmetry so
if you find that a full-size crossword
is a little too difficult we have this
thing called the mini it's a 5x5
crossword and it's actually free every
day you can just open up the app and
play it these are generated by by hand
by Joel Fabiano and if you start doing
them you can actually get on to a
leaderboard with your friends so you
could actually compete with your friends
at doing the mini when I was at the
times the games team was actually very
very competitive and I was usually top
three tough you know top four or my
former coworkers are shaking their hand
whatever and there are certain skills
that you'll pick up over time about how
to read the clues there's really like a
crossword ease language in doing these
puzzles like you'll notice that if a
clue has an abbreviation in it you'll
know that that answer will also be an
abbreviation so we have sec and the
answer is LSU or if the clue is
pluralized you'll know that the answer
has to be plural and field covers are
tarps and then if you pay attention to
the tents
if something is in past tense it'll be
in past tense in the puzzle it could
more often than not end in the letters
II D so even if you don't know the whole
word you could put it in easy and it
might help you get a crossing clue so
how does a crossword get made I get
asked this question pretty much the
first time every time I told someone I
work for the New York Times crossword
team they go oh you know that must be so
cool like you get to work with AI and
machine learning and maybe some NLP to
be able to generate all these puzzles
but in reality these get made the
old-fashioned way all of our puzzles get
submitted to us by people who make
crosswords by anyone who out there who
decides that they just want to make a
crossword generally it's a very very
difficult problem in fact I believe it's
it's an np-complete problem to generate
a crossword puzzle and sometimes
professors will do it in class they'll
generate like a 3x3 or a 4x4 but once
you get into these larger size boards
they become very very difficult to
generate especially because it's not
just about finding groups of words that
interlink together it's also about
making it enjoyable to play you need to
have a cool theme the words have to be
knowable by people who'd be doing that
day's puzzle it can't be some obscure
Prussian general and it can't be some
princess from the 15th century it has to
be something that most people would be
able to get so this is actually today's
puzzle you'll see that it was not done
by Will Shortz or Joel or Sam it was
done by Daniel Larson and his sister
Anne and then it was edited by Will
Shortz
Daniel submitted his first crossword
about two years ago at the age of 13 I
believe at the time he was the youngest
person to have a crossword published by
the New York Times and for this puzzle
he roped in his older sister Ann who
goes to Harvard and I know this because
Deb wrote a column specifically about
this puzzle and so if you actually want
to submit a crossword you have to do it
by hand and mail it in the old-fashioned
way
once they're they're mailed in it's fun
because you get to see Joel and Sam kind
of walk around the office with giant
piles of mail like papers and envelopes
just kind of loose like they're a
professor on the late to class and they
sit down and they go through all these
puzzles by hand they edit them by hand
they figure out if they're if they have
potential if they have a good theme if
they're clever if not they may send them
back to the original author and say hey
like this might need some work or if
it's kind of reached that level build
bring it in and they'll actually start
to edit it themselves generally they'll
edit puzzles very pretty heavily usually
rewrote rewrite a good section of the
clues sometimes they'll even modify
sections of the board if they find like
a corner or something is a little more
abstract I'll actually go in and try and
figure out new words that they can put
in there to kind of make the puzzle a
little more fun to play a little easier
just to fit the New York Times style and
they get a good amount of them they get
up to 70 puzzles a week by my last
measure so they have a lot of work to do
to actually just process all of these
and then once they've edited a puzzle
they sort them by weekday and have just
like a general cache of them waiting
around for them to publish so even if
you submitted a crossword and it was
good enough and they accepted it it may
just go onto a pile onto a shelf
for some Wednesday sometime in the
future but we're working on that we're
trying to get it a little faster a
little more clear
creating a puzzle is complex and it
takes time and it takes effort and it
takes expertise there are tools out
there that you can use to make the job a
little bit easier this is one it's
called crossfire it's from a website
that looks like this it's very
old-school but it'll actually give you a
little board and as you enter in letters
it'll try and find it will look through
its dictionary and try and find words
that accurately measured it can kind of
it's not guaranteed to give you a very
good puzzle but it can give you a
starting point to work off of and often
people who submit puzzles will have
their own dictionaries they maintain
their own word lists of words and
phrases and abbreviations and crossword
e's like you know cross or any words
that they can use in order to better
assist making their puzzles and if you
actually submit one and it gets accepted
and published we pay you a non
insignificant amount of money if you
submit an on Sunday we'll pay you five
hundred dollars and as you submit more
and more the pricing goes up and if you
get a Sunday publish that's fifteen
hundred dollars or overtime twenty two
fifty so it's not something you could
really live off of but we actually pay
people for their contributions so the
puzzle gets released every single day so
every day there's a new puzzle and
generally it gets released on the line
at around 10 p.m. so our back end has to
be able to handle these traffic spikes
so we actually send out a push
notification to people who have our our
apps it says hey new puzzle is available
come download it
so you'll see everyday we have this huge
spike where our traffic will go 1520 X
within a matter of seconds if you the
spike in the middle would be a Monday so
Monday generally has the highest traffic
the spike is a little taller and then
immediately falls back down over time
overnight in the morning it picks back
up so Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
Friday is back here on the left's on the
weekend we have a more interesting
pattern if you're into technical
analysis of stock trading or market
analysis you'll know that this is a
textbook sitting cat pattern and what is
special about this is the fact that on
the weekend the puzzle doesn't get
released at 10:00 p.m. it actually gets
released at 6 p.m. for reasons that I
don't understand
so you'll see a spike at 6 p.m. but you
also again see that spike at 10 p.m.
from the people who are habituated to
everyday at 10 p.m. go do the puzzle so
we actually see this dual spike of
people trying to download it but in
order to handle this traffic we had to
do some interesting things previously
before we rewrote it the back end for
the crossword was very inflexible and so
we couldn't scale dynamically to match
the traffic so we had to keep it over
provisioned at all times
to match the maximum amount of traffic
that we would see and that was very very
expensive so when we rewrote it we
wanted to make sure that we could
preemptively provision our back-end to
handle this traffic but not cost us a
ton of money we've learned to be able to
scale with this traffic so what we did
when we rewrote it was we moved to a
server list server lists backends it
kind of looks like this it's a little
complex this is also a little
out-of-date some of the
these hexagons don't exist anymore but I
generally like to think about it like
this so we've got a Games edge which is
a reverse proxy running on App Engine
which proxies traffic to all of our sub
services and the nice thing about App
Engine is that it's very scalable on its
own but we also did some interesting
things where we realized that App Engine
itself despite being able to scale very
well still could not scale fast enough
to handle our traffic spikes so what we
did was we sprinkled a little cron on it
so five minutes before 10:00 p.m. we
have a cron job that will hit an app
engine service and say scale yourself
scale yourself right now and App Engine
has the ability to actually modify its
own configuration on-the-fly where it
will boot up within a matter of seconds
hundreds of idle instances that are now
ready and registered with the load
balancer ready to take on traffic so you
see 10:00 p.m. we have this large
increase in blue idle instances and then
right at 10 p.m. as the traffic comes in
these idle instances become active which
is the pink area handles the traffic
spike and then five minutes after 10:00
p.m. we say all right App Engine you did
good scale yourself back down again
another nice thing about this back-end
is that when you're on App Engine you
can launch different versions of your
application like of a service so you
could have multiple versions of a
service out running at the same time and
you can arbitrarily split traffic
between them but when you launch a new
service what you actually get is a URL
that looks like this you get HTTP
service - dot - the project is calm so I
can hit an individual service with a
request and test out that it's working
even before I migrate traffic to it and
launch it to the world
and beyond that I can hit a specific
sort of specific version of a service so
if games puzzles is serving traffic I
can launch a test and hit that
specifically verify that the end point
returns data that I expect it to and
then migrate traffic over to the new
version and this allows us to do
essentially testing in production we
don't have to worry about affecting our
users because we'll just have versions
out there that aren't handling traffic
and that we can test with and then
eventually migrate traffic over and
that's kind of what this UI says we
launched a new version we want to
migrate traffic over it's just a few
clicks in the UI and the new version is
launched and if the if there's a problem
the nice thing is that you could roll
back right away you don't have to do any
fancy canary deploys or you know
splitting traffic splitting you can
basically just migrate traffic hundred
percent over you see an issue you might
agree 100 percent back Google is smart
enough to know that say you know we're
not going to delete all of your old
instances right away we're gonna keep
those hanging around in case we need
we're gonna gradually get rid of them
over time in case we need to split
traffic and move it back and lastly I
just want to say that despite where I am
if you want to work on these projects it
is an awesome team an awesome place to
work they are hiring possibly for a
back-end engineer physician and I also
wanted to say that just a little pitch
that they are remote friendly probably
remote first at this point in fact both
of our Android engineers on the team
work remotely full-time from st. Louis
and a smattering of other people around
the United States so if you're just give
them a look thank you
[Applause]
questions comments concerns criticisms
corollaries conundrums
unfortunately it's such a manual process
so he was mentioning a little while back
there were accusations of plagiarism
from a crossword submitter who had I
believe published puzzles and different
like in the LA Times and The New York
Times trying to kind of cheat the system
a little bit it's a hard thing to tell
and it's not something that we've it's
something that people have kind of
picked up on organically it's not
something that we've analyzed but
generally you know between will Joel and
Sam they've been in the krauser game for
a very long time they're very good about
editing their own puzzles they kind of
know what's been done and what hasn't so
there's not a strict you know checkpoint
to guard against that but it is a thing
yes so eventually those idle instances
will die off but we do have a secondary
cron to hit it and say hey you're done
scale back down basically decrease the
idle instances that you have so even if
there's elevator traffic App Engine will
have well we will know to keep instances
around to handle that but it says like
alright you don't need this many just
sitting around anymore
you can get rid of those so that way we
don't have to pay for maximum traffic
outside of that 10-minute window before
10:00 p.m. and after over here how does
the New York Times use go the New York
Times uses go for a lot of different
things the entirety of the games
platform are the games backend is
written and go the personalization email
messaging is all written and go
it's basically become the backend
language of choice within the company it
was introduced as just kind of a test by
a guy named Brian sites they wrote a
little app and deploy it out to
production and decided they really liked
it and so it eventually just picked up
steam especially because at the time
there was a smattering of different
languages the times itself is a very old
company does have a ton of things
there's C Java Python COBOL and some
areas and eventually just became oh
people enjoyed it they liked the tooling
that was built around it they liked the
performance they liked the ability to
compile a static binary and just put it
onto a server so it just in its own
right ended up eating the lunch of other
languages within the times it's general
in the back yeah you
yes there is a good feedback loop
between the people solving the crossword
and the people making it we have the
ability to update puzzles on-the-fly so
even after a puzzle is released we could
edit it change a clue the people making
crosswords and editing them are human
and they make mistakes and they have
typos and or even sometimes things won't
work as well as we expect them to like
if we have an emoji or something that
doesn't show up correctly usually we're
testing for these things when mistakes
happen so we're very Deb is very active
on Twitter people complained to her she
complains to us we complained to Joel
that it's the it's a process yes
so yes App Engine itself generally has
the ability to scale with traffic will
usually keep a few idle instances
running at all times
one two maybe five service handles an
exceptional amount of traffic so we'll
always have a few just sitting there
ready especially to handle little micro
spikes that you may see throughout the
day but that's a feature that's built
into App Engine it has the ability to
judging on the traffic that it's getting
scale up more instances as it needs it
so yeah fastly that is accurate we do
have fastly in front of some of our game
systems we don't use fastly as a CDN
more or less it's just something that
fronts all of New York Times comm
traffic that's because access to our
puzzle is a little complicated and based
around an encrypted cookie that fastly
doesn't have the ability to decrypt so
we can't host the puzzles statically we
have to serve it out of our application
servers but that might be something we
could change in the future
I don't know how we thought about
creating our own puzzle making and
editing tools all right so we're
rewriting the Wii they are rewriting the
new admin to have some of these features
to make uploading editing puzzles a
little more streamlined but right now
it's it's kind of an old-school process
that is an excellent question so why
don't we add all of our games to the
mobile app and we force them to just be
able be available on web I can't totally
explain why that's the case
obviously we launched it on web as a
prototype and it's existed there just
because that's the quickest way we could
launch it it's something that we've
thought a lot about it's just a matter
of determining how much business value
it has within the app itself or does it
go into its own app or you know where to
put it it's something that as being
thought about actively and with tools
like flutter and maybe it's a it'll be a
smaller problem in the future yes
the keyboard shortcut for the pencil you
want in the iOS app on web you should
submit some feedback
we have an entire feedback team and that
will be in front of an engineer very
quickly there you go yes we're using App
Engine standard right now and we're
moving to the second generation actively
yes
how often does it happen and what was
the second part gotcha so the question
was how often do people switch devices
and how does that synchronization
project our process work the answer is
it does happen a lot in fact some of the
more interesting bug reports that we've
gotten where some would someone would
say you know Oh like I opened up my my
puzzle and it was already half done or
was already completely already completed
and we can't figure out like you know
why this is happening they would submit
it as a bug and then we'd go into the
logs and say hey like you know we
noticed that you opened it on your iPad
but someone on their you know Android
phone was playing it earlier just by
looking at the user agents and they
would go oh my wife has an Android phone
she played the crossword
so generally does happen I do it all the
time I'll start a puzzle at work and
I'll play it on the ride home like I
described how the process works is so we
have a commit based solving system where
we take regular snapshots of your entire
board and it's state and submit that to
the backend and these are all saved in
our database which allows us to
basically replay the timeline of you
interacting with the puzzle over time so
that's how your progress is saved on one
device and then when you open it on
another device the first thing we do is
we say hey does this puzzle for this
user already have progress if it does we
just smash that all up and give you back
the latest state of the board anything
else I can't see if anyone has raised a
hand so all right thank you
[Applause]